en el último vídeo queríamos encontrar
la ecuación de un plano que contiene a
esta recta y que así está dada su
ecuación y que además sea perpendicular
al plano que contiene a estas dos líneas
entonces esencialmente lo que hicimos es
bueno pues si queremos encontrar el
plano que es digamos que es que contiene
a esta línea verdad a la roja y que
además es perpendicular al plano que
contiene a la línea morada ya la línea
azul pues entonces lo que tenemos que
encontrar es otro vector que permanezca
en ese plano para encontrar después un
vector normal como le hacíamos pues nos
nos tomamos este vector morado y este
vector azul verdad tomamos el producto
cruz de ellos y eso nos arroja un vector
b que fue al que llamamos de y este
vector d también pertenece al plano
amarillo entonces teniendo el vector
rojo que era a y el vector d podemos
hacer producto cruz para obtener un
vector que sea ortogonal a ambos o que
sea ortogonal o perpendicular son
sinónimos o que sean
ortogonal o perpendicular con eso basta
ok entonces ya que obtengamos esta n
estã n me va a determinar una
restricción sobre x jay-z en para
definir el plano porque porque n debe
ser ortogonal a todo este plano y
entonces eso ya me dice exactamente cuál
es la ecuación del plano ahora bien
la herramienta digamos o el truco
esencial que hemos estado utilizando en
este vídeo es el uso del producto cruz y
lo único que hay que recordar es que el
producto cruce entre dos vectores es un
vector es un vector y esto solo es
válido en el espacio de tres dimensiones
aunque el producto cruz de dos vectores
es de dos vectores nos da un vector que
es ortogonal a ambos que es
perpendicular a ambos entonces eso es el
producto cruz
y bueno entonces ya habiendo dicho esto
vamos a continuar lo que teníamos
queríamos calcular el producto cruz de d
con a para obtener nuestro vector n iv
que justamente se expresa de esta forma
muy bien entonces si continuamos esta
esta cuenta
vamos a hacerlo y vamos a tener lo
siguiente este este determinante que
llega donde nos habíamos quedado se
calcula de la siguiente forma me tomo y
quito su columna y su renglón y nos
queda uno por cuatro son cuatro menos
tres por 10 que son 30 entonces menos
treinta más cuatro son menos 26 y verdad
me quedo con él y ahora va con jota y va
aún menos quitamos renglón y columé nos
queda menos 8 por 4 son menos 32 y menos
2 por 10 son
- 32 son menos 20 y entonces menos 32 y
menos 20 son menos 52 pero con este
menos se hace más 52 jota
nos quedamos ahora con el cac quitamos
renglón y columna y nos queda menos 8
por 3 son menos 24 y menos 2 por 1 que
son menos 2 entonces nos queda menos 26
acá muy bien y este vector ya es no es
un vector ortogonal o un vector normal o
un vector perpendicular a todo el plan
muy bien sin embargo como realmente sólo
me interesa la dirección que tiene puede
apuntar hacia arriba o hacia abajo puede
ser chiquito o grande no importa
entonces si yo divido entre menos 26
este vector en seguir apuntando en la
misma dirección y si éste era
perpendicular al plano pues uno más
chico también y realmente quiero dividir
entre menos 26 porque si nos damos
cuenta todo es divisible entre 26
entonces digamos que defino un nuevo
vector vamos a llamarle
digamos en uno que también sea normal
pero es distinto de este n entonces esto
va a ser dividir este de aquí entre
menos 26 y entonces va a ser menos 26
entre menos 26 es uno así que sólo me
queda ahí 52 entre menos 26 es menos 2
que multiplica jota y menos 26 entre
menos 26 es 1 entonces sólo me quedo con
acá muy bien entonces digamos que más o
menos podría ser este de aquí nuestro n1
y ahí quedó y ahora el detalle es el
siguiente vamos ahora sí a definir la
ecuación del plano y eso se define
fácilmente porque si nos tomamos un
punto aquí digamos un punto x y z
y nos fijamos en el vector que se genera
que digamos nos fijamos en equis y más
jota más se está acá ok entonces éste va
a ser ortogonal con nuestro vector n uno
bueno con n o con n uno como ya tenemos
el n 1 pues es ortogonal a n 1 entonces
quiere decir que su producto punto debe
ser cero esa es una de las propiedades
de los vectores ortogonales verdad
entonces si nosotros hacemos producto
punto de este con el vector x y más j
más se está acá que este producto punto
nos debe dar 0 pero si ese producto
punto nos da 0 vamos a hacer las cuentas
y entonces simplemente multiplicamos
coordenada por coordenada y después
sumamos verdad entonces x por equis y en
realidad es x por y punto
pero y punto y siempre es 1 de hecho j&j
es 1 y cada punto cada uno entonces esto
sólo nos queda x y aquí va ahora llegué
y jota que multiplica menos dos jota
entonces eso simplemente es menos dos ye
y nos tomamos el último digamos este de
aquí que es acá punto se está acá y eso
simplemente es sólo z y esto es igual a
cero
entonces ya encontramos justamente la
ecuación la ecuación de nuestro plano y
luego a poner incluso con amarillo este
es x menos 2 maceta igual a cero ésta
es la ecuación de un plano y cual plano
pues el que estábamos nosotros
encontrando originalmente así que este
plan no tiene ecuación x menos 2 maceta
igual a cero esa es su ecuación entonces
después de todo lo que hicimos en el
vídeo anterior con todos estos con todos
estos vectores líneas y demás lo único
que faltaba era calcular nuestro vector
normal o nuestro vector ortogonal como
lo encontramos pues con el producto cruz
de de con a y recordemos que d
simplemente lo encontramos de hacer
producto cruce entre el morado que es b
y el azul que es c muy bien ya que hemos
encontrado nuestro vector normal o
nuestro vector perpendicular entonces ya
podemos calcular la ecuación del plano y
eso es porque este vector es ortogonal o
perpendicular a todo el plano entonces
si nos tomamos un punto en particular
digamos el x y z éste debe ser
perpendicular con el x y z entonces su
producto punto debe ser 0
debe ser 0 entonces sal va a hacer la
operación llegamos justo justamente a
esta expresión y así fue muy sencillo
resolver este problema bueno de
cualquier manera espero que te hayas
divertido en este vídeo nos vemos en
algunos próximamente